hello everyone this is going to be a bit
of a strange video but i am less than a
week away from my due date
um i'm hanging out at home just trying
to get
labor going so basically what you're
gonna see in this video i haven't
planned anything
like that's for one um i'm just gonna
start like
filming things whenever i get a chance
whenever my kid is not around
that's why you don't see me do a lot of
like wedding a day videos because
it's very hard for me to respect the
privacy of my family
while documenting an entire day but the
moments where i
am not with my kiddo then i'm going to
hopefully
bust out the camera capture a few of the
things that i'm doing um
a lot of them will be kind of just
hanging out trying to bring on labor
as well as i can um just trying to do
things that
bring me joy this week um because very
soon
i will not be sleeping and i will have
my hands full or i will be
in a lot of pain so um yeah i'm just
trying to
enjoy these last few days i don't know
i'm gonna film i haven't planned
anything which you know is so unlike me
so
yeah this is gonna be a bit of a weird
video for me let's see how it goes
[Music]
okay so being a good jewish mama and uh
making some chala today
it's not friday but it will be friday at
some point and i'm gonna pop this
into my freezer and uh
and then of course we can pull it out
for a beautiful shabbos dinner but
i've let my dough rise um i
love holla hello is the best bread if
you haven't had hot it's like an egg
bread
oh you can do it sweet you can do it
savory my mouth is watering just
thinking about it but it's definitely my
favorite bread
so let's shape some holla
so the sweet ones don't look as
professional as my savory sesame ones
but i am partial to the sweets
that is a truck
and these little goodies these little
these are just like little streusel bits
that fell off
and they're the best part that's
that's chef's little pre-bread treat
right there
it's like one of those like delicate
little lace cookies
one of those called tweels
tweels the ones that i get rolled up
twills
it's like a makeshift wheel i love it
let's eat those
okay so i know i said i wasn't going to
work today um
but i just need to watch a quick edit of
a youtube video right now while i'm
having my snack
um in case you're wondering this is some
kind cheese some yogurt greek yogurt
um some cereal for crunch and i threw on
some
leftover peach that my kid did not
finish at breakfast so
that's how we roll in mom hood we just
eat the leftovers until they're all gone
okay so now i'm gonna do something that
you cannot hang out with me for
that would get me demonetized for sure
um but i'm going to use my epino and my
epinos basically like this
device from germany um and there is some
not great but weak evidence to suggest
that it may help to reduce
perineal tearing and episiotomy rates
but basically it's like a balloon and
you kind of pump it up a little bit
every day to help
stretch the perineum and um just kind of
get it prepared
for having a 10 centimeter head
come through it and a lot of doctors say
it won't stop you from tearing which is
probably
absolutely true if you're gonna tear
you're gonna tear and if you're not
gonna tear you're not gonna tear
so there's so many factors um but i will
say used in my last pregnancy
and i had a seven seven seven pound
seven ounce baby
and i didn't tear i didn't have any
stitches which was great that's what i
wanted didn't have an episiotomy
everything went pretty well so i'm using
it again
um it was something that was recommended
like really a lot by my pelvic floor
physiotherapist
and um if nothing else
it definitely helps to prepare you for
the pain of childbirth
because it really hurts and you have to
kind of like learn how to
use your breathing and kind of breathe
through some of that pain
so i'll show you what it looks like but
i gotta use it
in private and you pump this up to
as big as you can handle it of course at
the beginning you're not gonna go
big because it hurts um
but yeah like okay so this is this is
ambitious
and then you gotta pull that out and
then you of course would just like
measure it
here on your thing and be like oh my
gosh i got to almost 10 centimeters or
whatever
and yeah you do a little bit each day
and
work your way up okay so now i need some
privacy um but again a quick disclaimer
again
that i'm not endorsing this product
speak to your healthcare provider your
doctor your midwife your pelvic floor
physiotherapist your whole team
if you're pregnant and you want to give
something like this a go i'm not
suggesting that you run and buy
something like this
at all but it was something that my
health team
recommended and um yeah i think i feel
like i had success with it so
it's worked for me all right i'm gonna
get a head start on dinner
um and i'm gonna do kind of like a
korean bootable situation
because i'm gonna use gochujang which is
super spicy and
as you know they always say that a lot
of spicy food when you're trying to put
yourself into
labor so i have no idea if that is an
evidence-based recommendation
but it i love spicy food so i really
don't care it's a good excuse
to kick up the spice a few notches so
i'm actually following one of my own
recipes so i'm going to just pull that
up
now on the blog i do it with like vegan
ground meat but i'm really just trying
to use up whatever i have in my freezer
right now
because i need to make space for the
baby milk which is
hopefully coming soon hopefully i have a
really easy go
this time with breastfeeding and pumping
um so
i'm using some organic ground chicken i
think is what i've got
thought out so i am going to
mix up some brown sugar tamari sesame
oil
crushed red pepper a little extra kick
gochujang which is
so delicious this is what goat this is
gochujang
and it's a it's a korean um spice paste
uh it's like chili paste basically but
it's kind of sweet and spicy and tangy
it is delicious it's like so addictive
and then some garlic and ginger and oil
and that's the base of
my sauce and then you basically mix it
with whatever you have whether you're
using a vegan meat or
ground beef or ground chicken or ground
turkey or it's delicious on
everything so let's do it
got some bell pepper some celery some
carrots
i'm probably going to add in some frozen
edamame at the end
some mushrooms the sauce of course
and some ground chicken or turkey i
think this is chicken
yeah and then we're going to make some
rice for it
[Music]
so spicy so good
it's gonna blow it's gonna blow her
heads off but
maybe you'll make a baby come and that's
that is the dream i thought friends
now we get down to business and do a
little acupuncture
[Music]
well we've got some good news and some
bad news folks
the good news is that today i went to
see the midwife and i also had
a pelvic floor physio appointment um and
that was really great because
i was able to determine that i am uh
three to four centimeters dilated and 75
of face which is pretty good i think
um definitely way better than where i
was at this point last time
uh so the midwife thinks that this could
happen anytime which is crazy
so today might be the day tomorrow might
be the day i don't think it's me
next week but it's soon so
now the not so good news is that i spent
the last
two days filming little vlog content for
you guys
and what happened
my card got corrupt corrupted corrupt
i hate technology i've tried to revive
it or
you know recover it no such luck folks
this is why i don't do a lot of this
vlogging stuff by myself
but anyways i can tell you what i've
been up to the past few days
uh i made a big batch of protein
pancakes for
me and baby e so i froze them they're in
the freezer
ready to go um and i've been eating lots
of spicy food we had some spicy
black bean tacos for dinner last night
which was
so good oh they're not really tacos they
were quesadillas and they're really good
and i had some
extra for uh for lunch today too so
they were delish um i've been doing
lots of squats lots of bouncing on the
ball
and i'm just charging my breast pump
right now because i'm going to try to
give that a go
and get moving on that because nipple
stimulation is another apparent way
for you to put yourself into labor i
guess
so we'll see how it goes and anyways if
i can get these bad boys
uh rocking and rolling ready for baby i
will probably be in better shape than i
was last time because
as i've talked about before
breastfeeding did not come
easy to me so let's see how far else i
go i mean this might be my last check-in
with you guys
which sucks because i had all this other
great stuff that i shot
sucks anyways let's go on with our time
this is my new pump we call her willow
that's actually what it's called um it's
my first time using it so apparently
it's
got a big learning curve it also makes
me look
pretty dusty i don't know i'm gonna just
say it's not a bad thing
so yeah i don't know if this was working
this one was definitely sucking this one
might need a little more
oh there we go
it is weird folks but gotta get those
nipples stimulated so that
we get those contractions going here's a
baby bump
pick let's see
oh see my
chiropractor and physiotherapist taped
me up
definitely helps me not feel like i have
to pee every five minutes so that's nice
um yeah
gonna go make dinner now please let this
work because it is not comfortable
okay so i'm gonna go for a little walk
now that it's not so hot
um in the day uh before dinner and i'm
gonna have a little snack before i go of
course
um i'm gonna have some dates and these
dates
i'm gonna dip in some tahini because
that's just a natural combination and we
got some healthy fats in there and it's
super delicious and
really helps to balance out the
overwhelming sweetness of dates and i
don't normally have dates as a snack
that's for sure
but this week i do because
there is some research and it's not like
amazing research so take it with a grain
of salt it's more just like a fun
factoid um but there is a little bit of
research to suggest that
uh eating i think it's like 60 to 80
grams of dates a day which is a lot i'm
probably not gonna eat that much i'm
gonna be totally honest
um but eating dates may help to increase
the likelihood of natural spontaneous
labor
um which is great it's kind of like
thought it was like
nature's induction candy so to speak
so and it's delicious so any reason to
have dates
is good and look at this drippy gorgeous
with the tahini
it's a great combo but it's gonna coat
my mouth and get gross so
i'm gonna save you the
eating and talking situation and just
try to do this the lady-like way
bye so um
this might be it my cramps are really
really picking up i'm getting
a lot of back pain and lower abdominal
pain
and i feel nauseous like i have no
appetite to eat but i know that i
should eat because if this is labor uh
i'm gonna need some energy
asap last time i was starving and i ate
12 popsicles on the ward i cleaned the
whole
ward out of popsicles so uh yeah i gotta
get some fuel in me so i just ordered
some ramen spicy ramen because
why not just make this happen faster if
it's gonna happen
uh and i don't even know if this is
happening so i guess we're gonna see
anyways i'm gonna go bounce on my ball
for a little bit until the food gets
here
and um my son is outside on the bike
with my husband and i can see them
outside and it makes me terrified
because he's
just whipping whipping down the street
um
that's i'm just rambling at this point
so let me just
go deal with this pain
uh well that escalated
quickly um so yeah that was
actual labor that i was experiencing
even though i was in complete denial
because it was all happening so
damn fast um but basically
i am currently for
five-ish five days postpartum um
baby o is sleeping on the floor
soundly actually i got checked because
yeah looks like he's okay looks like
he's happy
okay so i have a few seconds to chat
before
we got to get up and deal with that
situation but to very quickly tell you
about my labor
it was fast to say the least which was
really surprising to me
because um my son had to be induced my
oldest son e had to be induced twice and
it was even with the induction it was a
20 hour labor even with the second
induction was 20
labor and if you count the first
induction too it was like i don't know
like 48 hours anyways um
but basically what happened was that i
was having like mild cramping
early on in the day and um
and i just totally ignored it because i
was like pregnancy
it sucks it feels weird whatever and i
do apologize there's construction going
on outside because i live in a mad house
apparently
um and then i went for my midwife
appointment at like 9 00 a.m
she did a stretch and sweep and she was
like your cramping might get worse it's
just what happens with stretch and sweep
so
don't worry too much um and that's what
happens
well i was feeling the cramps all day
long and it just felt like period cramps
it wasn't like they was coming in like a
contraction-like wave
so again ignored them um i was
getting ready for dinner around like 5
p.m and i started to feel like
hmm these cramps are starting to kind of
come
and go and come and go just slightly um
but like still like perry cramps totally
tolerable
no problem but i let my husband take my
son
out for like a bike ride while i
prepared dinner at uh
five actually i don't think i even
prepared dinner i just decided to order
in
right um so i started to kind of clean
things up
and then by 6 p.m i was like trying to
eat my dinner and i was like
ugh i really feel sick and i feel
nauseous and i don't want to eat this
but i was like oh if this is labor
i'm gonna need to eat um so i was
pushing myself to do that um and so at
seven
i was like better call my parents let me
call my parents and just tell them
hey come over just in case if it's
nothing
whatever we'll watch some tv together
watch a movie it's not a big deal
um so they started heading over and by
like 7 30 when they got here i was like
this is labor i'd already talked to my
midwife she was on the phone with me
through a few of the contractions
my contractions went from like just like
having cramps as like a baseline pain
to about 20 second contractions every
two minutes it was very consistent every
two minutes
and you're supposed to go to the
hospital when they're like apparently
like 45 to 60
seconds in length but five minutes apart
but mine never were five minutes apart
they were either
no like they were they were nothing or
they were two minutes apart
so we left for the hospital um just
shortly after eight we got there like
maybe
quarter or two and by the time my
husband dropped me off outside the
hospital doors
i was doubled over in pain i was it was
excruciating the
drive there felt like the longest drive
of my life even though it was probably
like 10 minutes
um just because i had so many
contractions along the way that i had
no way to you know help myself through
normally i would like walk or like pace
or my husband would do some hip squeezes
or something
but i was just like stuck in a painful
small like car
cramped and i had to just like brace
myself um and i got out of the car i was
like
had like this wave of nausea and i had
to find like a garbage can outside of
the hospital
doors like beside like a few homeless
people while i was throwing up
um anyways as soon as that contraction
subsided i like bolted it into
the the hospital they had to do like a
coveted screening of course as soon as
they get in there another
i just rushed up to the the maternity
ward
and instead of um waiting to be checked
in like i was
should be waiting for my husband to get
there to check me in the woman at the
reception was just like
go go go to triage you could see that i
was like ready to go
um and so i got to triage and they were
like
uh you you know sit in this chair here
man um but
we don't have any beds we have 19 beds
and there's 23
patients who want to be admitted
um and who are in labor and i was like
oh my god what does that even mean
but of course i was in such you know uh
not with it that i just couldn't even
think about that at the time
so they put me in a like a little gurney
bed like in triage with a curtain
in the corner and my husband and my
midwife my
my midwife student came um
and we were all cramped into this corner
and i was
like terrified that i was going to be
giving birth in
the triage corner room
um because also there was no option for
pain relief i was like can i get an
epidural no can i get nitrous
oxide no they don't even have a baby
cart that would be
helpful when you deliver the baby so i
was getting really scared
because my contractions were like a
minute apart they were excruciatingly
painful
um i was like throwing up i felt
horrible and it was all happening so
fast
and i was worried that this would be
where i was gonna be giving birth and my
midwife asked like
do you want me to break your water
because you're actually only like four
to five centimeters dilated
but this is happening quick and if you
break your water i think this will you
know you'll have a baby really soon
but i was like i don't want to have a
baby really soon i want to be in a room
to have a baby because
you know i had a really bad postpartum
hemorrhage last time
and i was afraid of that happening again
and if it did happen again
let's just say you know i wanted the
epidural for that because
to have an adult's whole arm up inside
me scraping out my
placenta was not something that i wanted
to experience without
some pain relief so um thankfully at
around 10
45 the um they came in and said we've
got a room for you and i was
like oh my god hallelujah thank the lord
and they put me in a
wheelchair they like ran me to the room
and the second we got there the
anesthesiologist happened to be walking
by and i was just like get
in here help me help me
and uh and so i quickly got the epidural
and basically as soon as i got the
epidural i um
told the midwife okay break my water now
i went from five to ten centimeters in
dilated in about 10 minutes and then i
pushed for 20 minutes
and baby was born at 12 25
and so yes if you haven't been looking
at my community page updates
i had another baby boy which is exactly
what i expected to have you guys know i
talked about this
and i was saying i definitely think i'm
a boy mom for life and
um so it was definitely no surprise to
me when we
when we announced that it was a baby boy
and
we then um got into our hospital room
shortly after that
and next of course it was time to birth
the placenta which is what i struggled
with last time
and no surprise happened again i had
what they call
a retained placenta and as a result of
that basically
meant that my placenta wouldn't just
like come out
it wouldn't come out with pitocin or
kind of drug help
um they had to call in the ob to again
stick her
arm up me scrape it out while they like
punch on my stomach and push down really
really hard
to try to get it to dislodge and
it is really painful and uncomfortable
to have all that pressure on your
stomach
i can't even imagine what it felt like
to have the arm of me but thank goodness
i had the epidural still running um
so that was unpleasant and unfortunate
because it caused me to
hemorrhage so again i had a postpartum
hemorrhage
which is also what i experienced with my
son and um
that's always a bit of a scary
experience you know less so for me
because i just try not to
look at what's going on down there more
so for my husband who's seeing
what he considers like what he said was
just like like a bloodbath like a murder
scene
um but anyways uh that
made me feel pretty sick and weak
because of course i lost
um apparently i lost over like 1.2
liters of by blood
um and then we discovered that
my son and i have two different kinds of
blood types and as a result of that um
he was at higher risk of getting pretty
severe jaundice
and high bilirubin levels so we had to
stay for a little while um to have him
stay under the the little lights these
therapy lights that helped to bring down
the bilirubin levels to reduce the
jaundice
i hear a little squawker okay
back in a jiffy all right sorry about
that i had to do a quick little feed
um but anyways so the belly ribbon
levels went down
we got to take him off the lights we got
to go home
which was the best best news
and i got to introduce um e
2 0 and it was without a doubt the best
moment
of my life it was the moment i've been
waiting for and thinking about the
entire pregnancy and even before this
pregnancy and even before
the first pregnancy it was like there's
something just so magical
about seeing siblings meet
it was pure magic and he
has been such an amazing big brother it
just
has blown my mind i knew he would be
because he's
he's amazing and he's so loving and and
affectionate just in his personality but
i i've just been so blown away
by how he's stepped up to this role and
he just wants to help and he wants to
every you know every day he sees him and
wants to give him a hug and a kiss
and wants to hold him wants to help feed
him
um he's just being such a joy and both
of them together watching them
interact even though o is clearly just
like a newborn and
can't do much and can't say much and you
know they they can't relate to each
other yet
um i know that these two brothers are
going to be best friends for life and
it's just
it's exactly what i want um in terms of
me and my update things are going pretty
good uh i didn't tear so uh
in terms of my recovery it's been really
easy i guess
um i was back up and walking pretty
quickly uh
other than of course the fact that i was
like really weak and depleted right
after birth because of the
hemorrhage um i felt really good and
even though i'm tired i'm really hungry
i've got no time to eat like literally
all day basically
anything that i've eaten today have been
things that i can literally just shove
in my mouth
so i just ate a ton of fruit
um a couple hard-boiled eggs that was
that were already in the fridge
um i had a piece of bread with some
egg salad on it that again already in
the fridge because somebody brought it
over
and right now i had a wrap with some
peanut butter on it and like a banana
shoved in like
like a roll-up wrap so yeah i'm doing my
best here to stay
fueled because i'm starving but at the
same time it's like what can i eat that
i
only need one hand for because the other
one is always occupied
with one child or the other or feeding
it's just like back to back
and speaking of feeding it's going
better than it did with e but it's still
a bit of a struggle
um oh had both a lip and tongue tie like
eaten
and we were lucky enough to get them
released in the
um hospital but i'm gonna get a second
opinion tomorrow at the dentist just to
see if there's anything else we can take
away
because the lactation consultant thought
that maybe we could just like
snip a little bit more and see if that
gives me a little bit more relief
but we're just he's just learning how to
how to feed i'm just learning how to
you know work with him to make it less
painful
because he just doesn't want to open his
mouth wide enough to get that nipple
fully in don't you wake up buddy
don't you wake up give mama like five
more minutes
anyways we're doing a combination of
breastfeeding
basically like every two hours and then
i will pump right afterwards so that if
he needs a bit of a top up then i can do
that um
and also just trying to build my supply
which i'm just starting to get my milk
in right now because
because of the hemorrhage it was a bit
delayed so um
yeah things have been a bit of a
struggle but definitely not as big of a
struggle as they were with e
and i think part of that is just i feel
a lot more
confident and i feel a lot more laid
back about the experience
you know with e i felt like my entire
life revolved around
a schedule and a pumping schedule or
feeding schedule or sleeping schedule at
this time
i've just decided we're gonna go with
the flow because being a mom
of two children now i don't have the
bandwidth to
do anything else and it really was that
whole scheduling thing took away
so much from my motherhood experience
and i really just want to
kind of experience it in the moment this
time
so yeah that's where i'm at right now um
i was lucky enough to have a shower
today but i got up at 5 30 in the
morning just so that i could do that
before my
eldest son got up um so i guess that's
it for me right now i mean there's a lot
going on
it's a bit of chaos it's a bit of
craziness but i'm actually really
really loving it so if you've enjoyed
this vlog
kind of content let me know i definitely
feel like i could do a lot more of it
because
i'm home a lot more now so keep me
posted if this is something that you're
interested in seeing more of um if you
like this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any other
kind of specific vlog like content that
you want to see me do
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye wish me luck
in this craziness
[Music]
you